si catherine mercier bienvenue à la
semaine vers aujourd'hui à l'émission le
glyphosate c'est l'herbicide numéro un
dans le monde des champs de blé de la
saskatchewan où il est pulvérisé avant
la récolte jusqu en italie où il se
retrouve dans les pattes ils sèment la
polémique
mais at on raison de s'inquiéter je ne
comprends pas qu'on n'ait pas encore
fait un test du glyphosate à long terme
[Musique]
le glyphosate c'est la star des
herbicides ingrédient actif du roundup
de monsanto
c'est l'herbicide le plus vendu dans le
monde mais c'est aussi l'un des plus
controversés produit miracle ou
substances à éviter le glyphosate
pose-t-il problème pour la santé et
l'environnement
[Musique]
mais
l'agriculture moderne intensive et
industrielle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'immenses superficie monoculture
prise d'assaut par des géants équipé des
dernières technologies
et malgré deux formidables progrès et
fermi sont toujours confrontées au même
ennemi depuis des millénaires
parmi eux
[Musique]
les mauvaises herbes pour en venir à
bout
l'industrie agrochimique a développé il
ya une quarantaine d'années un produit
d'une efficacité redoutable
le glyphosate aujourd'hui l'agriculture
conventionnelle ne peut plus s'en passer
pas d'arrosage pas de récolte c'est
incontournable
on peut pas faire de culture sans
domicile pourquoi il est plus vendue aux
allemands parce que d'efficace et pas
trop coûteux puis elle en service ces
12,5 depuis quelques années le
glyphosate fait polémique
certains souhaitent l'interdire il
affirme que le produit est dangereux
pour la santé humaine et l'environnement
d'autres ne jurent que par lui mais que
sait-on au juste de cet herbicide
[Musique]
le glyphosate c'est l'histoire d'un
succès phénoménal celui d'une petite
molécule qui a conquis le monde
désherbant total le glyphosate a la
capacité de tuer toutes les plantes sans
distinction contrairement à d'autres
herbicides qui ne tuent que les parties
de la plante avec lesquels ils entrent
en contact le glyphosate allié à
d'autres agents chimiques à la capacité
de migrer une fois absorbé le produit et
diffusé dans toute la plante des
feuilles jusqu'aux racines
il empêche la production d'une enzyme
dont les végétaux ont besoin pour
survivre
en quelques jours la plante meurt
[Musique]
sa commercialisation par la compagnie
monsanto dans les années 70 marquent le
début d'une nouvelle ère le produit est
présenté comme inoffensifs
biodégradables
[Musique]
quatre décennies plus tard la popularité
du glyphosate est sans précédent
c'est de loin l'herbicide numéro un au
québec au canada et dans le monde
m
et
hamon
fin juin en beauce au sud de québec
stephen lagrange surveille six champs
ce producteur de grandes cultures a semé
du soya il y a quelques semaines entre
les rangs les mauvaises herbes sont de
plus en plus visibles dans trois
semaines les mauvaises avoir envahi soyo
province faire de bruit pas de traiter
roja réussit pas de récolte
[Musique]
oh
aujourd'hui son équipe préparent
l'épandage du glyphosate
ce qui explique la formidable popularité
du produit c'est une découverte majeure
des plantes modifiées génétiquement pour
survivre au glyphosate
[Musique]
quand on épand l'herbicide on peut donc
se débarrasser de toutes les mauvaises
herbes sans nuire à la culture
principale ici du soya
[Musique]
au canada la majorité du soya du maïs et
du canola est génétiquement modifiées
pour tolérer le glyphosate
l'adoption de ces cultures à partir de
1996 a bouleversé le paysage agricole
et fait bondir les ventes d'herbicides
utilisé en tandem avec les ogm au québec
en à peine deux décennies les ventes de
ces produits ont été multipliées par
cinq
oh
e
steven lagrange fait partie des premiers
utilisateurs de ces semences
quelques semaines après la pulvérisation
au glyphosate l'efficacité du produit ne
laisse aucun doute comme ses échecs
tout est mort
les reins mon serment billet toutes les
mauvaises âmes qui ont envie de
ressortir
ils vont se faire le trou et puis on
aura une belle régate
il
[Musique]
les herbicides à base de glyphosate sont
bien connus sous le nom ground up mais
il en existe plus de 750 variante
produite par différentes compagnies
à la suite de l'expiration du brevet de
mosanto en l'an 2000
le produit est une véritable mine d'or
avant d'être racheté par bailleur en
2016 monsanto affichait des revenus
annuels de plus de 6 milliards de
dollars seulement pour le round up
et au delà de leur utilisation avec les
cultures ogm et d'herbicides à base de
glyphosate ont révolutionné le travail
aux champs
un exemple dans la région de
saint-hyacinthe ce matin sous couvert
végétal va subir un traitement choc
aujourd'hui j'avais détruit avec du
griffon sable le champ de plants de
couverture qu'on assiste un champ qui va
être ça mais un haricot de conserverie
dans une dizaine de jours
traditionnellement avant de semer un
champ labouré
mais jocelyn michon a abandonné la
charrue
il y a plus de 20 ans c'est un adepte du
semis direct
cette technique permet entre autres de
réduire l'érosion du sol et économiser
du temps et du carburant au lieu de
retourner la terre le semis direct
conventionnelle repose sur l'usagé des
herbicides le plus souvent à base de
glyphosate
ils permettent de détruire chimiquement
tout ce qui se trouve dans un champ
comme ces plantes se met au printemps
pour enrichir le sol normalement je
devrais en fruits déchiqueté en fait des
résultats futurs mais régler face à
valence à couvert pendant des heures
quelques jours plus tard le contraste
est saisissant les plans qui ont été
aspergés d'herbicides sont
méconnaissables entièrement brûlé elles
tomberont bientôt d'elle-même au sol le
chant pourra être semées sans être
labourés
[Applaudissements]
mais l'utilisation croissante du
glyphosate entraîne des conséquences de
plus en plus de mauvaises herbes
survival herbicides
on ne peut pas utiliser année après
année toujours le même produit ça c'est
pas une bonne pratique il faut le
combiné avec autre chose sinon on risque
d'avoir des résistances à les mauvaises
herbes ses médecins dans les campagnes
l'arrivée du glyphosate a tout de même
permis de mettre de côté des produits
beaucoup plus toxique que je peux vous
dire c'est que depuis 15 20 heures on a
fait un grand pas dans les herbicides du
struthof allons triompher la culture
puis on a parti avec des produits
beaucoup comme la troisième qui ont
aujourd'hui on en utilise plus fait
qu'on ait beaucoup mieux qu'on était
[Musique]
un produit peut être moins dommageable
mais qui suscite tout même des doutes
le glyphosate est il aussi inoffensifs
que les compagnies veulent le laisser
croire
un peu partout à travers le monde
les manifestations se multiplient ce
soulèvement est propulsé par une annonce
du centre international de recherche sur
le cancer en 2015
cette agence de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé déclare le glyphosate
cancérigènes probables pour les humains
la nouvelle crée une véritable onde de
choc
monsanto rejette cette conclusion tout
comme plusieurs agences sanitaires à
travers le monde dont santé canada
n'empêche le glyphosate est aujourd'hui
omniprésente et se retrouve dans de
nombreux aliments consommés
quotidiennement
on le détecte également dans l'eau dans
l'air dans notre urine
en 2017 le doute est renforcée par la
publication et monsanto papers ces
documents internes de la compagnie
révèle que le géant des pesticides
savait depuis les années 80 que le dif
hosatte posait problème des toxicologues
de la compagnie avait découvert que des
tumeurs étaient apparues chez des
rongeurs
mais monsanto aurait manipulé la science
pour minimiser les dangers liés à son
produit vedette lemon saintot peppers
ont pesé lourd lors de la poursuite
intentée par dwayne johnson un jardinier
california est atteint d'un lymphome non
hodgkinien
il l'accusé entre autres le brandon
d'être à l'origine de son cancer en ou
monsanto est condamné à lui verser 285
millions de dollars américains le
montant sera plus tard révisé à 78,5
millions étonnamment malgré la gravité
de l'enjeu et la popularité du produit
les chercheurs n'arrivent toujours pas à
trancher
oui ça me paraît incroyable parce que
quand on regarde les récents
développements avec les peaux c est
toute la polémique sur le glyphosate
il ya des millions si c'est pas des
milliards qui sont en jeu et je ne
comprends pas qu'on n'ait pas encore
fait un test du glyphosate à long terme
sur une vie entière et que les
formulations glyphosate ne soit
quasiment pas testé
les analyses les plus longues menés sur
des rongeurs ne dépasse pas 2 ans
impossible donc de connaître les impacts
de l'herbicide à des moments clés du
développement
comme lors de la gestation
[Musique]
au king's collège de londres les
chercheurs robin ménages étudie les
effets du glyphosate sur la santé
humaine
c'est vrai que tout le monde se demande
si le roundup est cancérogène
il suffirait de le tester pour répondre
à la question
c'est pas plus compliqué que ça c'est
des tests qui coûte plusieurs millions
mais plusieurs millions c'est assez
faible en comparaison des sommes
astronomiques d'argent qui sont en jeu
plus de quarante ans après son
introduction dans les champs l'impact de
cet herbicide sur la santé restent
toujours à clarifier aux etats unis des
milliers de dossiers similaires à celui
de dwayne johnson pourrait déboucher sur
des poursuites judiciaires
autant de gens qui affirment que leur
cancer a été causée par l'herbicide le
plus populaire du monde
après la pause dans l'ouest canadien
des champs de blé pulvérisé au
glyphosate quelques jours avant la
rigole
[Musique]
désherbant quasi miracle le glyphosate
est désormais utilisée à toutes les
étapes de la culture du printemps
jusqu'à l'automne
mais certains des usages soulève des
questions parce qu'ils permettent aux
produits de se frayer un chemin jusqu'à
nos assiettes
[Musique]
des champs de blé blanc à perte de vue
cette céréale est l'emblème de l'ouest
canadien les paris sont le grenier du
canada et la saskatchewan est la
province où on en produit le plus
ce blé qui sert à faire de la farine du
pain des pâtes est au coeur de notre
alimentation
au sud d'origine a giclé guye cultive
plus de 5000 hectares de terre à la fin
où son blé est presque arrivé à maturité
il doit le récolter bientôt mais avant
il va pulvériser son champ au glyphosate
[Musique]
c'est une semaine avant la récolte il
sort l'artillerie lourde
[Musique]
un pulvérisateur de 37 mètres de largeur
doté d'un réservoir de 4500 litres
la pulvérisation au glyphosate après
récolte permet de contrôler les
mauvaises herbes comme le chardon les
pissenlits le coach ya dans ces plantes
prolifèrent dans les champs au moment de
la récolte elle ralentir l'avancée de la
machinerie les mauvaises herbes
secouristes dans la boue sonneuse et
elle finit par s'arrêter quand elles
sont toutes ses chais morte ça
fonctionne beaucoup mieux mais pour les
fermiers ce traitement après récolte
procure un autre bénéfice
il permet d'assécher un champ en entier
le plan n'est pas une plante
génétiquement modifiée pour survivre au
glyphosate
quand cette céréale est aspergé
d'herbicides il lui arrive la même chose
qu'aux mauvaises herbes
elle meurt
mais pourquoi vouloir tuer le plus
quelques jours avant la récolte
d'accords commerciaux
si vous regardez un champ commercial
cité comme celui ci vous voyez que même
s'il a la triple à il n'est pas uniforme
[Musique]
david guez est un agronome à la retraite
il explique que les plants de blé d'un
bout à l'autre d'un champ n'arrive
jamais tous à maturité en même temps
[Musique]
si on venait dans ce champ du snel avant
la récolte vous verrez qu'à certains
endroits le blé mûr caisse % d'humidité
il est prêt à être récolté et on verrait
aussi des zones vertes
le taux d'humidité est de 40 % de 50
[Musique]
pulvérisez au glyphosate amène tous les
plants à maturité en même temps plus
besoin de faucher le blé est d'attendre
qu'il sèche comme autrefois
il est prêt pour la récolte à une date
précise
l'enjeu est particulièrement important
dans l'ouest où les surfaces de culture
sont immenses
les fermes sont de plus en plus grande
et la récolte est devenu une course
contre la montre
on cultive 5000 hectares et en
aviculture différente cette année
alors c'est très important d'arriver à
des récoltes et rapidement le traitement
après récolte nous aide parce qu'ils
accélèrent la moisson mais il ya un hic
le produit n'a jamais été homologué pour
faire mûrir les plans il est autorisé
seulement pour contrôler les mauvaises
herbes par le monde agricole
un flou entoure son utilisation
[Musique]
plusieurs le reconnaissent on pulvérise
même des champs où il n'ya pas de
mauvaise herbe
c'est un mauvais usage du produit mais
on ne doit pas l'utiliser comme agent de
ses charmes pour accélérer la maturation
c'est pour contrôler les mauvaises
herbes et semaines fruits
[Musique]
en saskatchewan le ministère de
l'agriculture estime que selon les
années jusqu'à 70% du blé est traitée
avant la récolte mais il n'existe aucune
statistique officielle
les herbicides à base de glyphosate sont
en vente libre et leur usage est laissée
à la discrétion des agriculteurs
[Musique]
et le blé n'est pas la seule plante sur
laquelle le glyphosate est utilisée
après récolte l'avoine l'orge les
lentilles les pois le lien entre autres
peuvent également être pulvérisé
quelques jours avant la moisson
[Musique]
une situation qui ne préoccupe pas jake
les goûts et mes enfants me manque
ces aliments ça ne m'inquiète pas du
tout des agences gouvernementales à
travers le monde ont conclu que le
glyphosate et sécuritaire pourtant de
nombreuses études scientifiques
concluent aujourd'hui que si cette
application quelques jours avant la
récolte qui laisse le plus de traces
dans nos aliments
la pulvérisation après récolte elle pose
problème parce que c'est la source la
plus importante de résidus de glyphosate
on pulvérise juste avant la récolte donc
la plante a pas le temps d'éliminer les
résidus qui faisait il se retrouve dans
l'assiette du consommateur en 2017
l'agencé canadienne d'inspection des
aliments a révélé les résultats
d'analysés effectuées sur des
échantillons de nourriture au canada
près de 37% des produits céréaliers
contenait du glyphosate
tout comme environ le tiers des aliments
et des céréales pour bébé très peu
d'échantillons dépassé les limites
permises mais ce que l'agencé ne révèle
pas c'est que dans les produits
céréaliers
on a inclus ni le prix ni lavoine nil
maïs qui sont pourtant de loin les
céréales les plus cultivés et parmi les
plus consommés au canada
on a plutôt retenu les taux de
glyphosate dans des céréales comme le
miel l'amarante et le sarrasin des
produits peut pulvériser en pré récolte
est beaucoup moins courant dans nos
gares de manger mais qu'en est-il de
produits qu'on mange tous les jours
comme le blé l'avoine
une seconde étude contenant les
résultats d'analystes ces céréales
devait paraître en 2018 mais sa
publication a été annulé nous avons mis
la main sur les résultats ils sont d'un
tout autre ordre sans dépasser les
normes 80 % des échantillons de blé
contenait du glyphosate tout comme 74 %
des échantillons d'avoine
ces résultats n'ont jamais été rendues
publiques
l'utilisation du glyphosate a pris son
envol grâce à des cultures comme le soja
et le maïs génétiquement modifiés
destinés à l'alimentation animale
[Musique]
aujourd'hui son emploi en pré récolte
sur des céréales qui se retrouvent
quotidiennement dans nos assiettes
soulève de nouvelles questions
c'est une pratique qu'il faut regarder
de près et évaluer pour voir si ces
résidus vont poser problème pour le
consommateur
récemment l'application de glyphosate
entrée récolte a été interdite dans
plusieurs pays d'europe en république
tchèque en autriche en belgique en
italie au canada cette pratique se
poursuit
mais des voix s'élèvent même dans le
milieu agricole pour la remettre en
cause
[Musique]
après la pause dans le blé canadien
n'est plus le bienvenu
[Musique]
on l'apprend à l'école depuis qu'on est
tout petit exporté à travers le monde
notre blé et l'un des piliers de notre
agriculture mais ce pilier montrerait-il
des signes de faiblesses de l'autre côté
de l'atlantique des consommateurs qui
compte parmi les plus fins gastronomes
de la planète lève désormais le nez sur
notre blé le port de bari sur la côte
adriatique
c'est la principale porte d'entrée des
céréales étrangères en italie c'est
aussi dans ce port que se joue l'une des
batailles de ce que les italiens
appellent désormais la guerre du blé
juin 2010 est une manifestation de
producteurs de bill la télé italienne et
sur les lieux hollande événements
arrivent à la retraite je me fallait les
ballons trop bas
les agriculteurs bloquent les camions à
la sortie du port les camions qui
transportent du blé canadien que les
producteurs locaux jugent moins 5 e le
lard du blé qui se retrouvent dans les
pattes dont les italiens sont les plus
grands consommateurs au monde
ce navire parti du port de vancouver
contenait 50 mille tonnes de blé dur
canadien depuis les importations en
provenance du canada sont en chute libre
entraînant l'érosion d'un marché d'un
quart de milliard de dollars le canada
premier producteur de blé au monde n'est
plus bienvenu chez le premier producteur
de pâtes
saverio debonis est agriculteur et
sénateurs il fait partie des forces à
l'origine de ce soulèvement
nous l'avons rencontré à rome canada de
nombreux agriculteurs italiens sont
allés au canada et ils ont découvert que
là bas on utilisait le glyphosate pour
encourager la maturation artifices ya du
grain quand ils m'ont dit ça pour la
première fois je n'y croyais pas puis
nous avons découvert que dans les pâtes
italiennes
on retrouvait la présence de cette
substance
[Musique]
puisque l'italie interdit l'usagé du
glyphosate en pré récolte sur le blé les
agriculteurs italiens soupçonne le blé
étrangers en italie
celui ci vient alors principalement du
canada
pour y voir plus clair saverio debonis
fonde en 2016 un groupe de défense des
consommateurs granos à luz il veut faire
analyser la présence de contaminants
comme le glyphosate dans les pâtes
italiennes
les premiers résultats créé une
commotion en italie toutes les plus
grandes marques de pattes des fleurons
de l'industrie agroalimentaire italienne
contiennent des résidus de glyphosate ne
touchera l'intérieur des limites
permises
ce qui ne rassure pourtant pas saverio
des bonus et limitent les limites
imposées par l'union européenne sont des
limites de nature économique
j'oserais même dire industrielle au fil
des ans ces fameuses limites ont été
rehaussés parfois même à la demande des
fabricants d'herbicides à base de
glyphosate
non pas parce que de nouvelles études
faisait état que le produit était
sécuritaire mais plutôt parce qu'on en
détecter des niveaux toujours plus
élevées et nouvelles limites reflète une
réalité agricole le glyphosate et par
tout ce qui est en italie suscite de
l'inquiétude
basta non ok d'ossip qu'est ce que dit
la science c'est qu'il nous faut qu'une
faible dose pour avoir un effet
endocrinien une action d'interférences
sur les hormones il n'y a pas de 12
maximales et minimales la recherche
indépendante ici en italie a démontré
que la présence de cette substance même
à faible dose causera du tort car il
s'agit d'un perturbateur endocrinien et
les résultats de plusieurs autres
analystes suivront avec des constats
similaires
pratiquement toutes les grandes marques
de pâtes italiennes contiennent des
traces de glyphosate les fabricants de
pâtes conteste ces résultats et
poursuivre grano salis en justice mais
coup de théâtre
face aux géants des spaghettis la petite
organisation aura gain de cause
[Musique]
aux cris des militants l'information des
consommateurs et la sacro-sainte je
pense que le droit à l'information des
consommateurs et sacro-saint et que
l'industrie qui nous nourrit avec ces
aliments devra accorder plus d'attention
aux caractéristiques toxicologiques de
ce que nous ingérons la sensibilité des
consommateurs à ce sujet va grandir un
plus en plus l'industrie des pâtes
considère quant à elle qu'on a crié au
loup
[Musique]
fondée à parme en 1877 barilla est le
premier producteur de pâtes au monde
les analyses qui ont été faits
démontrent qu'il n'y a pas d'enjeu de
sécurité alimentaire tous les niveaux
étaient bien en deçà des limites
permises on parle de centaines de fois
en deçà des lignes les pâtes sont donc
sécuritaire mais le gillon a tout de
même dû réajuster le tir
l'inquiétude des consommateurs était
trop grande
la compagnie a donc revu à la baisse ses
propres limites parilla qui toléraient
autrefois une teneur de glyphosate de 10
parties par million ppm ce qui est la
norme acceptée en italie a aujourd'hui
fait passer sa limite à 0,1 pt m c'est
100 fois moins
[Musique]
les exigences envers nos fournisseurs
sont de ne pas utiliser de qui croisa
avant la récolte est de livrer du blé
dans lequel on ne détecte pas cette
substance malheureusement les
producteurs canadiens ne sont pas
capables de rencontrer cette exigence
depuis plus d'un an les exportations
canadiennes de blé dur vers l'italie
autrefois le deuxième plus important
client du canada ont diminué de façon
dramatique
de plus d'un million de tonnes par année
elles sont passées à 290 milles tonnes
une baisse de plus de 70%
[Musique]
dans les prairies on considère que le
glyphosate n'est qu'un bouc émissaire la
cause de la dégringolade des
exportations est simple les italiennes
font du protectionnisme ils refusent
notre billet en disant ce que vous
faites est mal on n'en veut pas mais il
ya eu des enfants sur les limites
permises le blé dur canadien vendus en
italie et respecte ses limites
alors pourquoi ne pas l'accepter les
italiens essayent de changer les règles
du jeu pour que ce soit plus difficile
d'accéder à leur marché en voilà
pourquoi c'est une barrière commerciale
comme beaucoup d'autres agriculteurs
dans les prairies todd luiz est d'avis
que les italiens exagère
les canadiens dimanche ce livre ne le
considère pas comme empoisonné et ne
l'est pas certaines des choses qui ont
été dites sont complètement déconnectés
de la science ce sont des opinions qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la réalité
tant pis pour les agriculteurs canadiens
sont en colère parce qu'ils pensent que
cette technologie n'a pas d'impact sur
l'organisme humain
mais s'ils savaient ce que nous savons
aujourd'hui nous qui sommes aussi
agriculteur en plus d'être consommateurs
il comprendrait les raisons de notre
combat
[Musique]
à 100 km au nord de la capitale dans une
région historiquement surnommé le
grenier de rome
nous avons rendez vous avec federico
ancelotti et mittal ya en italie notre
glyphosate
vous le voyez très bien ce soleil c'est
lui qui fait mûrir le blé
producteur de blé conventionnel il
possède une terre de 80 hectares il
explique que les fermiers comme lui ont
commencé à se poser des questions quand
le prix du blé italien a chuté
la colère est apparu lorsque le blin
passé d'un pays que nous pensions
correct à un effondrement total en
corolle au total et
au même moment les navires en provenance
du canada font de plus en plus la
manchette
les agriculteurs italiens qui produit
sans glyphosate en pré récolte se
sentent lésés
oui mais au contraire c'est un non sens
que l'italie importe du blé canadien
avait du glyphosate
c'est absurde parce que nous nous
essayons d'avoir de bonnes pratiques
pour la santé des consommateurs
puis on va importer du blé deux pays
nous on utilise ce produit pour forcer
l'industrie à plus de transparence et
syndicats agricoles et les organismes
comme gran au saloon 1000 et auprès du
gouvernement pour un nouvel étiquetage
départ depuis février 2018
les fabricants qui transforme le blé en
pâte ne peuvent plus inscrire simplement
produits d'italie ils sont tenus décrire
le lieu d'origine de l'ingrédient
principal ici le blé comme le blé du
canada a été démoniser en italie pas
question d'en faire l'ingrédient
principal des pâtes
ottawa juge que ce nouvel étiquetage
pénalise les producteurs d'ici et
songerait à déposer une plainte devant
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ironiquement toute cette histoire
éclabousse même les producteurs de blé
bio du canada et protagonistes les plus
improbables dans ce conflit depuis que
tout ce débat a déjà fait baisser
l'auvent de 40%
alex galarneau est à la tête d'une
entreprise familiale de céréales
biologiques arad ville dans le sud de la
saskatchewan
l'italie est de loin son plus gros
client un client de plus en plus
exigeants le problème c'est que pour
certaines certifications bio le niveau
accepté c'est maintenant 0
dans un environnement où il ya de la
contamination par tous 0 c'est presque
impossible
la saskatchewan est la province qui
compte lui plus de producteurs de grains
biologie
éparpillés sur le territoire ils ont
souvent comme voisin des producteurs
conventionnels utilisateurs de iphone
[Musique]
nous avons des fermiers dont les terres
sont entourés de prairies naturelles qui
n'ont jamais été cultivé pour votre
iphone et même là on détecte du
glyphosate près de quatre ans
[Musique]
pour s'assurer que ces cargaisons ne
soit pas rejeter une fois arrivés en
italie
la compagnie prélève désormais des
échantillons qui sont analysés par des
laboratoires européenne avant que la
marchandise ne soit expédié ses
contraintes logistiques coûte une
fortune
près de six cent mille dollars l'année
dernière seulement
[Musique]
l'image de l'italie est indissociable de
sa cuisine la sensibilité croissante des
consommateurs italiens amoureux de leurs
pattes dicte désormais le marché
le vieil adage le dip le client est roi
et les producteurs de blé canadien août
en conventionnel que biologique en font
aujourd'hui les frais
ok
après la pause le glyphosate est il un
herbicide en sursis
le glyphosate a été réautorisée au
canada une décision maintenue malgré les
révélations des mots sainte open
mais le processus d'approbation de ce
pesticide a de quoi laisser songeur
[Musique]
avril 2017
le gouvernement canadien annonce que le
glyphosate herbicide le plus utilisé au
canada et dans le monde et sécuritaire
pour la santé et l'environnement
il est rigolo gay pour 15 jusqu'en 2032
au même moment l'union européenne fait
preuve d'une plus grande prudence
là bas on reconduit le glyphosate pour
cinq ans seulement
pourtant le centre international de
recherche sur le cancer une agence de
l'eau oms a déclaré le glyphosate
cancérigènes probables pour les humains
mais pourquoi une telle divergence
d'opinion entre autres parce qu'on ne se
base pas sur les mêmes études
l' agence de l'eau ms n'a regardé que
les études publiées dans des journaux
scientifiques des études indépendantes
révisé par les pairs
[Musique]
du côté de santé canada on s'est basé
sur des centaines d'études fournie en
grande majorité par l'industrie
cette situation a fait sursauter
plusieurs chercheurs dont louise
vandelac qui a émis un avis d'objection
à la décision de santé canada
quand on s'est mis à regarder
attentivement les documents on se dit
mais ce sont essentiellement des
documents non publié des documents donc
secret auquel on n'a pas accès venant
d'une industrie qui bénéficient de la
décision c'est quand même un peu anormal
[Musique]
lorsque l'on examine de près la décision
finale on constate qu'en ce qui concerne
la santé humaine sur 636 étude près de
80% sont fournies par l'industrie
une situation qui ne sort pas de
l'ordinaire selon santé canada
tous les organismes réglementaires
mondiaux utilise la même approche que ce
soit pour les pesticides bobinska mais
c'est dans la nature de ce genre de
système et ce n'est pas tout les études
retenue ne date pas d'hier
bon nombre d'entre elles remontent aux
années 70 et 80 au début de la
commercialisation du produit
pourtant près de 70% des recherches
indépendantes sur le glyphosate dans les
domaines médical et biologique ont été
publiés au cours des dix dernières
années
quand on procède à une réévaluation et
faut avoir les données les plus récentes
de la littérature scientifique pour être
en mesure de voir s'il ya des problèmes
c'est rarement l'industrie qui met en
évidence les problèmes qui se passe
le ministère se défend d'avoir écarté
des études indépendantes qui aurait
soulevé des problèmes liés à la
des études plus récentes n'ont pas
nécessairement répondu à toutes les
questions de type réglementaire parfois
c'est des chercheurs qui pose une autre
hypothèse que je cherche à trouver une
réponse à une autre question
pas nécessairement qui sont pertinentes
dans le contexte d'une réglementation de
pesticides
mais comme la science évolue très vite
les résultats obtenus il ya 40 ans ne
tiennent pas compte d'enjeux inconnu à
l'époque
il y a vingt ans par exemple on se
posait pas la question des effets
perturbateurs endocriniens parce qu'on
les connaissait pas ou alors très peu
maintenant les nouveaux tests qui
doivent être faits doivent aussi prendre
en compte ces nouvelles découvertes et
étudier les effets sur les hormones
pendant le développement les effets
neurologiques cdc des effets qui n'était
pas forcément être bien étudié il ya 20
ans lors de ce tournage les chercheurs
consultés ont également souligné le fait
que contrairement à l' agence de l'eau
ms santé canada considère surtout la
toxicité du glyphosate pourtant cet
ingrédient est jamais vendu seul dans le
rwanda le principe actif le glyphosate
ne représente qu environ 40% de la
formulation d'autres molécules sont
ajoutés la raison pour laquelle la
majorité des institutions toxicologiques
sont sur le principe actif s'est passé
vraiment la molécule qui est le plus
susceptible d'influencer les risques à
la santé humaine ou à l'environnement
pourtant ce n'est pas ce que les
chercheurs ont découvert on a fait des
études où on a comparé la toxicité de
neuf formulation de glyphosate qui était
différente et on a vu que le glyphosate
n'était pas l'ingrédient le plus toxique
l'ingrédient qui était le plus toxique
c'était un de ces formules ans qui est
considérée comme secret industriel et
ils étaient dix mille fois plus toxique
que le glyphosate
pour arriver à identifier ces molécules
qui peuvent avoir de puissants effets
notamment sur les cellules humaines
les scientifiques sont forcés de jouer
pour détective
il
c'est que ces informations sont classées
confidentielles pour accéder à certaines
données de l'industrie
il faut se rendre à ottawa muni d'une
déclaration sous serment dans une salle
de lecture on peut consulter certains
documents ce fonds environnementaux et
photocopies et les photos sont
interdites
mais si santé canada connaît l'identité
des molécules qui accompagne le
glyphosate est possible pour le public
ou les chercheurs d'obtenir cette
information
les agriculteurs épandent donc à grande
échelle un produit sans connaître la
liste complète de ces ingrédients et
comme on ignore ce qu'il y a dans le
contenant d'herbicides
il est impossible pour les chercheurs
d'évaluer l'impact de l'effet cocktail
autrement dit les interactions entre les
différents pesticides qu'on utilise en
agriculture et qui peuvent se retrouver
dans nos assiettes
aujourd'hui plusieurs voix s'élèvent
pour revoir le processus d'homologation
des pesticides
mais en attendant qu'est ce qu'on fait
je plus honnête que je pensais sur le
terrain certains cherchent des moyens de
réduire notre dépendance aux herbicides
pour lutter contre les mauvaises herbes
entre les rangs markul côté ses
étudiants utilisent la force de la
nature
ils sèment des plans bénéfique qui vont
occuper l'espace
on utilise certaines réserves pour
couvrir le sol et faire une fonction de
contrôle des changes mauvaises herbes
cette 4e place
celle qui pousse trop et qui dépasse
finalement les plantes de culture des
plantes d'intérieur la proche du
professeur lucotte n'élimine pas
complètement le glyphosate mais permet
d'en diminuer l'usagé cette utilisation
plus modérée est aujourd'hui crucial car
au fil des ans
herbicide numéro un dans le monde à de
troubles en effet sur le sol
[Musique]
comprendre ses effets il faut revenir
aux années 60 à l'époque le glyphosate
n'est pas connu comme herbicides
mais plutôt comme créateur de métaux
l'industrie s'en sert pour désincruster
la tuyauterie et se débarrasser des
dépôts de minéraux
sauf que dans le sol l'appellation a des
effets pervers
quelle nation qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que la molécule a le
pouvoir de faire comme les pinces de
crabe et au milieu des pinces
il va y avoir de manganèse du cuivre du
phosphore et donc la plan sera incapable
d'aller chercher le phosphore goût
d'aller chercher le manganèse pour la
fertilité du sol
ledit foissac pose problème une fois
dans la terre ils se dégradent
mais ces molécules dégradées ne
disparaissent pas année après année
elles s'accumulent
résultat elle prive les plantes de
l'engrais qui se trouve naturellement
dans le sol
je retrouve avec des sols magnifique
comme par des sols que nous avons ici
dans la plaine du saint laurent
rempli de phosphore de manganèse de tout
ce que vous voudrez un objet de rajouter
des engrais chimiques contiennent ces
éléments là pour compenser le fait
qu'une partie des éléments se retrouvent
prisonniers
après plus de 40 ans d'utilisation les
herbicides à base de glyphosate qu'on a
longtemps considéré inoffensif nous
force à repenser nos façons de faire
ce pesticide est tellement utilisé dans
le monde qu'on peut pas l'interdire du
jour au lendemain
faut une transition douce et il est
important pour les agriculteurs qu'on le
veuille ou non qu'il soit toxique ou non
donc il faut étudier les alternatives il
faut voir si elles sont plus toxiques
voir comment on peut les utiliser et la
transition à se fera sur des années pas
du jour au lendemain
[Musique]
il n'y aura pas de solution miracle pas
de nouvelles molécules qui viendra
remplacer le glyphosate de meilleure
rotation une tolérance plus grande
envers les mauvaises herbes ne sont que
quelques pistes pour se défaire peu à
peu de la dépendance à cet herbicide
il faudra avant longtemps rétablir la
confiance du public
les impacts potentiels sur la santé
soulève déjà trop de questions c'est le
cas pour le tabac l'amiante et bien des
produits chimiques ont on attend 10 15
ans avant d'agir alors que
il ya parfois des preuves scientifiques
qui sont là depuis depuis 15 ans et
c'est à ce niveau là qui est peut-être
que le principe de précaution pour être
plus utilisé
[Musique]
du coup
oui
[Musique]
pour poursuivre la réflexion sur le
glyphosate
ne manquez pas les émissions l'épicerie
mercredi soir et enquête jeudi
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine première d'une
série de trois émissions sur la faune
sauvage en ville au canada et aux états
unis
deux grandes métropoles abrite des
populations d'animaux sauvages des bêtes
qui se sont adaptés à leur nouvel
environnement
[Musique]
la côte est de l'amérique du nord est
recouverte d'une immense forêt qui
s'étend du québec à la floride
[Musique]
c'est une forêt tempérée reconnaissable
à ses arbres à feuilles caduques à
l'ombre desquels vivent de nombreux
animaux comme les ours noirs les serres
à queue blanche où les ratons laveurs
depuis des siècles les humains
transforme ce paysage des villes ont
remplacé les forêts les espèces animales
qui ont survécu ont appris à vivre dans
ce nouvel habitat voilà c'est ce qui
complète notre émission merci d'être
fidèle au rendez vous et bonne semaine
verte
[Musique]